[MUSIC PLAYING]
STANLEY SHAW: The
frameworks in this course
will be helpful to anyone in a
digital health company whose work
touches the product or the customer.
And the insights can help health
system leaders evaluate and implement
digital solutions.
So wherever you sit in the
digital health ecosystem,
this course will help you navigate
the needs of key stakeholders
like patients, doctors,
payers, and innovators
and how to leverage digital
tools to create value for them.
And you'll understand how the culture
and real-world practice of medicine
makes digital transformation
in health care
entirely different from
transformation of any other field.
[MUSIC PLAYING]